[Música]
hola soy ariana said cantante y
activista de los derechos humanos de las
mujeres de afganistán
[Música]
he sido activista de los derechos de las
mujeres y activista de los derechos
humanos en afganistán y de tu sabes
hablado claramente en contra de los
talibanes por muchos años y literalmente
tenía miedo como qué pasaría si entran a
la terminal y me atrapan aquí sabes ese
sería mi final y el de mi novio en 2011
sobre driving entonces estábamos
manejando y pasamos por como cinco
puntos de control talibán eran como las
once de la noche y uno de ellos paró
nuestro carro y uno de ellos puso una
luz dentro del carro y cuando me vio con
un niño pequeño y obviamente estaba
cubierta con un hiyab solamente podía
ver mis ojos y estaba usando anteojos
también simplemente fue aterrador
para ser sincera con tigo ahorita estoy
sentada acá en washington dc y aún no me
siento normal todavía tú sabes estoy
traumada y no puedo creer que he tenido
que pasar por todo esto y no creo que me
lo merezco tú sabes como ser humano
quiero decir hacer música cantar porque
es un pecado tan grande quiero decir por
qué porque tengo que ser tratada así y
todas estas mujeres por las cuales hablo
en afganistán y que estoy pidiendo por
sus derechos básicos porque no deberían
tener sus derechos a tener bytes
aguantar the way to be back quiero
decirle a las mujeres que no se rindan
vía algunos vídeos recientemente sobre
las mujeres yendo a las pistas y están
tratando de tú sabes pedir por sus
derechos eso realmente me gusta tú sabes
pero que puedan seguir y luchar el
tiempo que puedan
[Música]
con esta